Speaker 1: Let's go to Chris from Iowa.
Chris, welcome to the program. What is on
your mind today? Chris from Iowa, please.
Speaker 2: Can you hear me okay? Yes.
Wonderful. Okay, So speaking of culture issues,
I think the profession that has been affected
the most has been the teaching profession and
education in general. Mm hmm. And so my question
is, how do people who are in the profession
combat that without getting in trouble or
going against the grain? I mean, it seems
like there are times when teachers just
do not have a voice in what's going on.
Speaker 1: So in some sense, it sounds
like what you're saying is teaching has become
unbearable for teachers because you've got all
these kooks saying, I want to decide what
books and material you're teaching. I want
to decide how you're teaching it. I want to
decide about masks. I want to decide about
vaccines. I don't want this. I don't want
that. Is that that's why the teaching has
become so difficult.
Speaker 2:
Yeah, it's a lot of outside pressure and noise
and and also it becomes difficult because it feels
like we we don't have any really any power to do
anything about it other than keep just keeping
our heads down and doing our best. So, dude.
Speaker 1: You're breaking up a little bit,
Chris. But here's here's the thing, and I hate
that this is the reality. I think that teachers.
Can't do it on their own. I think teachers
are going to need the support. At minimum,
at minimum, of the teachers unions and the
principals and the superintendents and probably
of local elected officials as well in order
to be able to establish. We're not going to
be bullied by parents if you show up and act
out at a school board meeting or whatever.
You're not going to get your way. That's not
the way to actually have your voice heard.
I believe that teachers need to be supported
by all of these different elements. It can't
just be teachers going, Hey, I'm going to teach
what I'm going to teach. Because the truth is,
particularly in states that have passed laws
about these things, they'll just get fired.
They'll just get fired. And then that's not going
to help anybody, particularly not the students. So
I think it's going to take a team effort.
Speaker 2: Okay, Well, that helps a lot.
Speaker 1: My boy, Chris, his connection
is a mess. So, Chris from Iowa,
we're going to let you go. Do appreciate
hearing from you. Super important issue.